who do you think your audience is though
obviously there's people that want to
see your films I think it's the people
who take who take the time and
appreciate seeing movies that are
non-commercial that don't follow the
same old fast-food style entertainment
people that really enjoy discovering
something that they would not have
enjoyed before because I look at movies
these days the studio movies it's like
fast food it's like going to McDonald's
I'll take the number-6 supersize that
bad boy cuz that's what I want I've had
it before it may look a little different
I may be I may be getting the
cheeseburger instead of the instead of
the McRib or whatever but I've had it
before I know what it tastes like I know
what it costs and I pretty much know how
I'm going to feel after I eat it that's
what Hollywood movie is today instead of
trying that new restaurant on the corner
with the new chef and he you know you
may love it or you may hate it but in a
lot of people these days aren't willing
to take that risk and this the big boys
and the studios they don't want us to
take that risk they want us to say no
you're gonna like this because we know
what you like we know what kind of car
you like what kind of food you eat what
kind of clothes you wear and what kind
of movies you see and don't argue with
us because we already know because we
make all the money when you give us all
your money so it's a grim tube answer
your question for independent film very
grim unless you're a guy like Alexander
Payne who is a in my mind a very
successful regional filmmaker he makes
films set you know up in Nebraska he's a
regional guy and he's able to penetrate
a wide audience cuz you know
he's figured something out or you have
guys like Jim Jarmusch who's like this
euro-american director who gets
financing from Europe because he's big
over there and they appreciate his films
and this films do better over there than
they do here so if you can figure out a
way to like out to sort of play the game
but
be smart and strategic enough to have
people play your game
I think that's where it's at for
independent film and very few people can
figure that out
very few talented people can figure that
out so but those two guys I just
mentioned have figured it out that's the
best example I can think of
you